[Applause]
[Music]
all right we're you I got some live
practices in Aikido get Josh am I out
here okay so when we're talking about
live practice in Aikido generally the
idea is it when people say oh let's add
live trained Aikido they think oh we
need to have some kind of sparring
practice which is direct conflict and
that's how we're gonna get better at
Aikido we're not gonna get better like
in it that way you might get better
jiu-jitsu that way but you're not gonna
get better I get that way because I can
use a different set of skills so we have
to find ways to introduce live
practicing Aikido that works towards the
skills we are trying to acquire so the
skills were trying to acquire are gonna
be distancing clearing how to keep
suppression in all these kinds of things
these are the kinds of skills we need so
we're gonna outline a really simple
drill here that we go from a to Zed here
and we'll kind of see how we can build
this practice up so the first thing is
Josh of course should be trying to keep
distance from Maya right so if Maya was
attacking Josh Josh always wants to keep
distance and that's the idea so he's
trying to stay away from her we don't
have enough room right now to make that
work so we're not gonna worry about that
drill although that is a drill we need
to work on which is a distancing drill
but if Maya is able to get closer to
Josh - Josh would like he's got to learn
to deal with that now she could get
closer to him because a she's just
faster than him - too fast Josh can't
even go as fast he wants she's still
quicker than him she could get him
locked into a corner in some way right
so you know josh is trying to get out
and he's doing a good job but my lock
him into a corner or in some way Maya
quit surprised josh Josh didn't know the
kind of attack was being launched right
so that any of those things could happen
in those three key happens all right now
what works so when we're simulating that
what josh is gonna want to do is get off
line and suppress so Maya came in
Johnson get off line and suppress now
you see all you did all the right things
right there good line up just like that
perfect okay Cece I did all the good
things he got out of the way the attack
suppressor arms or arms couldn't reach
in and get
and then she went right by now that of
course is a great way to look at it and
when we're start looking at geo Aza
that's the kind of way we look at it or
we look at Keenan agonic forms that's
the way we look at it but that's going
to become more and more challenging as
time goes on so the way we're gonna
progress this drill is like this first
we're gonna start with just that Maya's
gonna come in and push Josh josh is
gonna get pushed it's important that
your bouquets know that the attackers
know that that is their job is to come
in and push now of course that push
could end up becoming a grab so she
could push into a bear hug or she could
shove them super hard all those kind of
things to happen but that's the first
thing we need to train to do k to
actually make an attack Maya doesn't
want to run into Josh encircle Josh like
this hey and this is what I you know I
tend to do right so you know I'm
attacking Josh I come up that go do you
technique group do you technique bro do
your technique bro great so so that
pollutes him to do so we gotta stop her
occasion doing that life practices she's
actually gonna come in and push it
perfect now let's we have okay who's
doing that we can start to get some more
realistic responses
now if Mile is actually attacking Josh
and Josh just get off the line it could
look like this
and now we have Josh being a perfect
split-second decision to enable that to
happen but more likely Maya's gonna
adapt when Josh adapt so when josh
adapts Kamiya minds gonna adapt to jump
right so he got off the line but Maya
was still able to come in to push him
because she was a had enough time that
she could see what he was doing
so what josh tries to do is get
suppression in order to do that so he
comes in he gets suppression and that
keeps her from being able to change the
line so the next thing is can the muguet
adapt to you and you deal with new
pigment that was just a little perfect
okay now how do we evolve that practice
further now Maya can attempt to get
around Josh's suppression so I'm gonna
go real slow this isn't the speed we're
actually gonna go but Maya's gonna come
in josh is gonna suppress and Maya's
gonna go around that suppression so she
how she moved around his arm so she
come to get to him right so that's what
my is trying to do now so now when Josh
does that we're gonna go full speed here
in a second when Josh does that josh is
a suppression is gonna have to adapt to
- oppression so as you come in CC ah she
made her arms weren't just long coochie
whirring attempt and he slid in through
the inside right now if you come out
tons away could be a battle the hands
the hands could go up and down right so
if Maya comes in towards Josh her hands
are moving up in the out of Josh through
the seat or just after we change the
line so maybe you can't win the
spreadsheets interview Jennings once she
comes in he suppresses she's there he'd
be changing a lot he had to adapt to the
life okay so our next practice is to
teach nage how to adapt to an adapting
okay right so Luke is trying to get
around George how do you get good at
that what kind of stuff can you do to
get good at that
and if you run these basic drills you'll
start getting better at that
all right now as good as Josh can be
it's still always quite possible that
Maya is better and Maya will get a
successful hold so as Maya comes in just
try to suppress Maya's gonna get around
it
and she's gonna get a whole so right
here she's gotta the door all right
let's freeze at that point all right so
why is gonna come in there we go and
josh is trying to get free here but
she's got us caught the door so she
fancied that now look my second hanging
out here all day so she's going to
follow this up with Kenny a more teasing
or something so Josh only has a split
second to deal with this so Josh need to
learn Hadopi from this drill Hey so as
my comes in Josh try to suppress my it
gets around it we're gonna have a
successful graph and the Josh has to
clear
and there he has it cleared right okay
now we would run those full time right
so I'm gonna have you right now you guys
are gonna go through your just a set of
these for the guys so we're gonna see
what happens if we're just gonna run it
so my is every time coming in trying to
grab job Josh every time is trying to
keep free if you can't keep free
he's gonna try to make the dough
all right now you might be asking a few
questions right like why doesn't Maya
just stop okay now we have to go back to
the whole philosophy of icater to
understand this if Maya ever stops josh
is just going to make distance right -
meaning - moving top speed to get Josh
if she stops only top speed
Johnson she's gonna make distance so if
my chooses to come in and do one of
these kind of numbers like a football or
something Joseph just gonna keep making
distance right then Maya will have to
adapt right so meaning if I come in on
this guy and I rush in like this and I
go then josh is just gonna make distance
while I'm doing it so when he makes
distance if I want to get him what do I
do I have to take off moving again
and then if before I grab him I don't
want to make a mistake I stop
josh is again making distance right so
this is what's happening in this every
time they stop because josh doesn't have
to detect Maya and in fact doesn't want
to attack my he's just gonna make
distance from her right so Maya comes in
and Josh is going to move off the line
suppress and trying to free my is going
to try to adapt to that suppression so
this is a basic suppression drill you
can use that's teaching nage to deal
with an ever adapting okay I'm just
trying to psych Peter president thanks a
lot
[Music]